everything you've heard about cuphead is
true it is an incredibly difficult
side-scrolling shooter with relentless
boss battles that demand rapid-fire
actions and reactions making up the bulk
of its gameplay toppling these imposing
bosses is both a monumental and
rewarding task but difficult boss
battles only tell half of the story Cup
heads 1930s cartoon aesthetic is
endlessly charming popping with color
and expression unlike anything seen in a
videogame before the sheer variety of
characters and settings yields
consistent delight as you go from one
stage to the next
with everything bearing the tell-tale
signs of grainy thirties film and
rudimentary production techniques the
characters and bosses that are clearly
inspired by cartoon legends like Betty
Boop break free from the expected to
surprise you with something new
nevermind that Betty's look alike as a
mermaid now it's the moment her head
breaks free from her body and lures you
into a tightly designed cavern while
spewing Skull filled projectiles that
gives you pause you can appreciate the
unique animation style you will be
doubly impressed when you see what
developer studio mvhr has brought to the
table if its technical execution wasn't
enough and ehrs creativity puts cuphead
in a league of its own outside of
one-on-one fights you also have a few
opportunities to running going through
less imposing platforming stages these
help break up the action and give you a
chance to collect coins that we cashed
in for weapons and passive bus coins are
in short supply and can only be
collected once so farming to gain an
advantage is out of the question
the mix of weaponry you have to pick
from which are character fires from
their fingertips includes the likes of a
spread shot a charged blast and a
boomerang round there are six in all and
each comes with a secondary attack
that's tied to a meter which fills when
you successfully land shots on enemies
you can also earn meter by pairing pink
projectiles a task that requires you to
jump and then tap jump again at just the
right time before make in contact with a
projectile finally you have a super art
which can only be fired when your entire
meter is full as opposed to spending one
section of that meter to fire your
secondary attack the one catch here is
that when your meter is full you have no
option to perform the secondary attack
alone you are in conveniently forced to
unleash your super art which isn't
always desirable every boss fight
consists of multiple stages or forms
bosses will change shape
position and behavior with each new
phase and within an individual phase you
may see as many as four different
attacks
though you aren't always guaranteed to
see them all which keeps up the element
of surprise the fear of the unexpected
is part of a mix cuphead such a
thrilling game beyond the frantic
moment-to-moment tension as you hold on
desperately to your three hit points or
four if you equip a charm that weakens
your firepower in exchange for health
but when the only question in your head
is and what order will the boss attacks
appear fights take on a new life fatigue
and frustration are common reactions
when faced with a particularly
challenging battle and it's in these
moments you start to identify a few
places where cuphead could do a slightly
better job of keeping you informed of
your own progress and capabilities
beyond bosses changing phases you can
never tell exactly how close to death or
a phase change for that matter they
actually are at best you can see a
plotline of the battle after death to
gauge your relative progress given the
array of weaponry at your disposal you
may begin to question if you're carrying
the right tools for the job but beyond
revisiting old fights which is actually
more arduous than it should be as you
traverse the map slowly and can't fast
travel there actually isn't a great way
to familiarize yourself with new weapons
and there's unfortunately no way to tell
exactly how much damage one weapon does
compared to another big descriptions are
all you get
if cap heads fights were indeed puzzles
with one correct solution this would be
incredibly frustrating as it stands
there's only a small amount of
frustration to be found while fumbling
with new weapons and dying in the
process and it may sound like a minor
thing to praise but the fact that boss
battles reload in one or two seconds is
a godsend when it comes to trial and
error tactics
cuphead does support two-player local
co-op as well but it's pretty evident
that this makes life more difficult for
you and your partner
despite the intricate chaos that you
face alone in any given fight when you
add a whole other character and more
projectiles on screen playing with a
friend makes it far more difficult to
discern your surroundings and much
easier to slip up and so far as we can
tell boss's health scales up when we
play with a friend now you do have a
small annuity to revive a fallen comrade
by parrying their ghost but it's a mere
few seconds while it floats up to the
top of the screen before disappearing
for the remainder of the fight for
anyone interested in getting a taste of
cuphead without facing its ultimate rack
there are simpler versions of every boss
that you can fight but you'll be able to
face the final bouts unless you beat
every standard boss on the normal
difficulty in reality you may as well
stick with the standard fights as
cuphead is relentless no matter how you
play
[Music]
but that has been a long time coming and
it's great to see that it lives up to
its initial promises it's beautiful to
look at with a pitch-perfect soundtrack
to boot and it perfectly captures the
era this developer is so clearly revered
it's also an intense action game that
pulls no punches it makes every shot you
land feel like a minor victory it could
benefit from a few options to
familiarize yourself with your weapons
and two-player co-op doesn't feel like
the valuable addition you might imagine
but cuphead remains a rare unique game
that truly stands out
[Music]
you